[Musique]
on connaissait depuis longtemps au moins
de vue le satellite mise au point aux
états unis dans cette sphère
les appareils enregistreurs des
appareils radio promis pour 57 le
lancement avait été reporté en 58
les essais de la fusée de lancement
ayant tourné court
et brusquement on apprenait que le
satellite russe avait commencé sa ronde
extraordinaire à 900 km d'altitude
il tournait à 28 milles 800 kilomètres à
l'heure autour du globe
abattant ses 640 km par 24 heures
aussitôt les antennes ce côté le ciel
lee moore est le premier centre des
coupes de france à avoir d'effets les et
enregistrer les émissions de cet engin
le premier qui est atteint l'espace
extra terrestres et bientôt enregistrer
les signaux émis par le satellite elle
et être dans toutes les oreilles
car cet appel strident sollicite
étrangement l'imagination en attendant
le satellite continuer sa ronde suivie
de la dernière partie de sa fusée de
lancement et les hommes scrutez
naïvement le ciel pour essayer de voir
l'étonnant de choses qui les inquiète et
qui les émerveille
[Musique]